it's half year results time for bp and
as we saw with shell last week it is a
very good time to be in oil and gas so
firstly this is the big number that
everyone is focusing on bp's underlying
profits that's once you remove all those
one-off costs and investments it was 6.9
billion pounds in the months of april to
june that is the highest quarterly
taking in 14 years let's put it in a bit
of context have a look at this compared
to the first quarter this year it's a
bit of a jump up but just look how it
compares to the same period of time in
2021 bp
tripling its profits in just one year
the wider context is important as well
bp says of course that all this profit
is being reinvested in green initiatives
in energy security share buybacks and
whatnot but he would also say it is
beholden to the market in good times and
in bad and times haven't always been
good for bp just look what happened uh
in 2020 those big losses that
experienced at the beginning of the
pandemic really struggling to recover
but look profits now up to significantly
more than they were pre-pandemic and the
reason for that well it is the spiraling
cost of wholesale gas and wholesale all
let's just have a look at oil in
particular look as you can see this is
the period post pandemic it was
gradually rising up as demand really
returned but look at that big spike
there that is when the ukraine war broke
out and although it's fluctuated a bit
it has remained stubbornly high now none
of this would be particularly
controversial were it not for the fact
that at the same time many families are
really struggling to pay their bills so
have a look at this is the energy price
cap this is the maximum amount that
companies are allowed to charge their
customers first bar is what it was
before all this began uh second bar is
what it is now about 2 000 pounds a year
and just look what is going to happen uh
according to forecast this winter a
massive jump up again in excess of 3 000
pounds a household uh probably according
to forecast but what's really scary
about this is not how high the prices
are but how long they're going to endure
just look what happens when we head into
the summer next year peaking potentially
at over 3 600 pounds of family so lots
of discussion about what can be done
about this the tory leadership
contenders they say things like cuts to
vat cuts to the green levees but when
you actually break down
what these costs are made up of look
that red bit most of it is made up from
that wholesale cost the smaller bars vat
policy costs they are really uh small
comparatively now a whimful tax of 25
percent has been imposed on the big oil
and gas companies that may help families
a bit but in the face of numbers like
these there are many who say it simply
doesn't go far enough